but how about this how about I'm
dropping my graft at school this morning
it's the first time I've ever
embarrassed them so our thing is Rick
and Morty we always watch Ricky boy
before he goes to bed and their sister
there's the atmosphere on Rick and Morty
where they have like all their friends
all the friends are popping up they're
actually aliens we put disguises their
friends and they're bringing back old
memories and then they pop up in the
house and their old uncle with this
Italian guy in New York pops up his name
I think uncle Vinny or something like
that and this whole catchphrase it makes
no sense he goes I'm walking here right
so you know that's from what that's
actually from a movie called
urban cowboy oh really Dustin Hoffman
played a guy who was a street urchins
from the street guy yeah
when when he was in the cab almost hits
him with his cross because I'm walking
here yeah so yeah that's from yeah so
that's this this his uncle of the family
it's his only line like she they they
get trapped an elevator and he pops he
like saves them and they go oh Uncle
videos I'm walking here like it makes no
sense
my gran died Oh we'll just ran and I go
I'm walking here and then he'll say it
back so he's there with his little
friends and the teacher has his arm and
I'm like light on your love yours love
you and I go I'm walking here AHA the
teacher turns around she goes quiet and
I go oh nothing and then she looked at
ayissha's what'd your dad say and
usually Tiger says it back he said
nothing just shook his head I could tell
he was so embarrassed
this [ __ ] embarrassment
you remember those moments there might
be nothing worse than being I felt so
stupid I'd return I goes what I go no
and then I'm looking at Tiger girl I'm
walking here and he just shakes his hand
I'm like oh when you're younger your
biggest fear is embarrassment let me
make that argument you high school
middle school that your biggest fear is
embarrassment being embarrassed oh dude
I held in every fart from from [ __ ]
first grade till I was a senior in high
school I did
no one heard me for what's Bubba now I
was in when I was in my studio my
freshman year in high school I was
because I had to go to boarding school
and I was new to America and I was
[ __ ] in Massachusetts and I was
eating at some [ __ ] you know boots in
the cafeteria and I grew up on food from
the countries I was in and I was trying
to I was those years those plastic tears
[ __ ] rip they just they betrayed me
betrayed me at a kid you know when I was
going to school today maybe it was the
school I was in they didn't separate the
kids they did separate the kids with
special needs and the regular students
for like resets like so we would eat
with everybody man even the kids who
don't have it who were special and there
was this kid man and he just he wore
matching sweats every day you know he
was a little bit on the special side and
everybody everyone was so nice to him
nobody ever bullied him everyone took
care of him he was like you know
everyone loved him and thinking back on
something
cool but he always wore the same blue
sweats he had multiple sweats really
wore those every day and his underwear
stick out the back like his whitey
tighties but this kid just no [ __ ]
Gibbon he just fought the loudest farts
you've ever heard and this is how cool
the kids were in the fourth and fifth
grade no one least no one made fun of
them everyone just kinda was like that's
that's Roger you know like that because
and I think that kind of like as a 37
year old man if that kid farted right
now I would bust out laughing you know
I'm saying when we were in Italy my
sister myself my budding Rea Brianna and
his brother and his wife and we were we
were getting on a train and there you're
gonna think I'm joking it was somewhere
in the butt [ __ ] [ __ ] Italy we saw
one dude who had blond hair who was
wearing a swastika around his back he
was wearing a gold swastika he was a
[ __ ] fascist and he was blond and
really muscular and we were like holy
[ __ ] we're early and then there was a
family and you're gonna think I'm joking
of inbreds
they were a family of immigrants they
were a family mom dad kids and they they
were they were not they were dangerous I
said to my sisters failure and there's
Thomas's room they're eating and I this
is a I could hear them there was a
chorus of farts were farting as a family
do I remember going back to my son how
embarrassing I felt so bad as much
driving away I remember when I was in
3rd or 4th grade i sat next to my
biggest crush name was Kathy Lee
something I remember I just I had to
pick my nose and we're watching a movie
and they sat me next to her and whatever
earth science does it go aliens the hot
chick got such a big crush on and when I
was picking my nose and I lost it [ __ ]
did it go and then we're watching the
movie and then I like said something
about whales I was like how about this
sperm whale am i right and as I as I say
something she goes oh my god I know what
she was you have a giant in front of the
whole class she is you have a
right Booker right here dude oh dude I
reached up I felt that I owe you I you
could I wanted to die I literally wanted
to die that's like the girl I was 18 to
21 I couldn't believe she liked me in
college again - [ __ ] freshman year at
college I have the worst cold on boy
because what's that on his sweater
yellow [ __ ] snot and we both
pretended we didn't know I had snot all
over my [ __ ] fall sweater
no dude when I was when I was a freshman
in college we're not so big I've been a
sophomore I was registered in Colorado
I bought this or I watch this pit bull
named pig he was this little tiny pit
bull puppies cutest fun and you know
he's a puppy I didn't know how to raise
a dog let roam around my [ __ ] dorm
room well he must have took a [ __ ] take
a [ __ ] on my scene football issue hoodie
that I wore all the time yeah it was
great and so I put I must've went to the
bathroom at night
sweep the [ __ ] under the hood II woke up
the next morning at [ __ ] you know
school early sent him
I put the hoodie on and I'm and I the
whole the whole time I'm driving and I'm
walking like this was like I give him
the class in my friend goes God did some
growing away goes brah you got [ __ ] on
your shirt hey I had a pile of [ __ ] just
a [ __ ] pile of [ __ ] dude on my
sweater there was a gal in college I
still remember she was so beautiful
she was her father would have been black
him out of his white she was I couldn't
believe she liked me I [ __ ] couldn't
believe it and then we ended up having
sex in my apartment and as we were and I
was like oh
like her body was I was like I can't
believe she likes me I'm just like this
is it was just like one of those young
man experiences like holy thought and my
dog came [ __ ] she says there's been an
accident and I smell of course what
smells like only fresh dog [ __ ] my
[ __ ] pickle my [ __ ] dog is squatting
and taking the biggest [ __ ] next to us
[ __ ] dog buddy hey buddy you don't
take a [ __ ] right there
especially anyway dude you never forget
these things like the first time I was
making out with a girl I was doing in
front of like between classes first time
ever kissed a girl and this guy Jesse is
my friend Cameron I figure his last name
Cameron well Cameron Wilson I'm making
out with a girl in this you know like
watch like damn and he pulled my pants
down all the way down so my ass cheeks
and dick her out the front that's a
problem because when your dicks not
ready you don't want people seeing your
dick when you've just been walking
around it's not flattering I'll never
forget it man I'll never forget that
[ __ ] and tell you this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]